like visas currently pending so
um and the only reason I'm on house
arrest is because of my immigration
status so if I were a citizen United
States citizen like I would not be on
house arrest nor would I be banned from
social media so and I voluntarily chose
to
um
kind of stay here and to figure
everything out so hopefully people will
um give me some credit for that
thank you
like so many of us think we know you we
have seen your story play outs money is
not an issue for me what's you wearing
you look poor
so who is the real annadelity
gosh I guess that's a loaded question I
guess I'm still figuring it out so you
are out of jail you served two years at
Rikers and you've been under house
arrest for how long
five weeks so what does house arrest
entail it's 24 7 confinement I mean I
can move anywhere within the building
and you also have to wear an ankle
monitor correct oh that's right yeah
okay
can we see the ankle monitor yes
Anna through the tabloids dubbed the
fake German heiress is waiting to hear
if she'll be deported are you writing a
book I tell all maybe yes like I've had
so much written down it's like I don't
know like I'm looking for the best time
to actually like
um publish it because you're not like my
grandma gaze is still on Direct appeal I
sat down exclusively with a 31 year old
in her one bedroom East Village
Apartment her rent 4 200 a month Anna
sketches which are basically paying the
bills hang on the walls so where did you
create this work uh I made it earlier
this year while I was in Orange County
Jail what do you project your annual
income to be this year from your artwork
I think I got off 300 000 maybe I don't
know okay so some people may say
is this annadelavy scheming again what
do you say to those people
um um I mean I don't know I'm just like
I'm just selling my art I don't know how
would you describe your art well I'm I'm
Pokemon at myself in the events I've
been through
um for my sketches there's always a
sense of fashion tied in has anyone
surprising purchased a piece of your art
oh my gosh so many people did I mean um
Kawaii Fineman she purchased the SNL the
Saturday Night Live run it on my card
this is a metro card
I don't know like all kinds of people a
lot of lawyers purchase my Brands why do
you think that you know lawyers are
loving your artwork
I don't know I would like to I would
love to hear from them why they love it
is it a daily practice for you to create
some sort of piece of art or work on it
during the day
um I try to yeah so I try like to sketch
like
um
write down some ideas yeah I don't like
necessarily draw every day because it
just entails like a lot of setup and um
yeah but I do sketch a lot okay so I
imagine you find yourself with a lot of
time here at your apartment since you
are under house arrest
um just some of the basic things how do
you go about getting your groceries do
you cook do you order your food tell us
a little bit about your day-to-day life
uh well so far I've been actually pretty
busy having lots of meetings but um I'm
not allowed to leave so I have to order
everything in okay so I'm like using
um Uber Eats or doordash or caviar or
like people bring me stuff okay are you
a cook
I am not uh I mean I'm sure I'll get to
it but I have like a sculpture on my
stove right now yeah it doesn't look
like you've been doing a lot of cooking
around here anna but maybe you could who
knows it could become a new hobby
um they did they did teach me how to
cook or how to bake cookies in prison so
maybe I'll you had you got to learn how
to bake cookies in Frozen what else did
you what new skill sets did you learn in
prison
um I mean that's pretty much it I mean
because I'm vegetarian or do you work
out do you do any kind of like yes I
have like a skipping rope really I hope
your neighbor's okay with that I bet I
don't know neighbors downstairs yet okay
that's good that's good news well one
thing we know that isn't a part of your
daily life is social media
how are you managing that are you coping
okay with not being able to post on the
gram
uh I guess
option off like six weeks last year yeah
you went to town on the six weeks last
year that you had available to you you
went to Dale is that normal that they
strip social media from people who are
under house arrest no it's not so then
why do they do that to you I think it's
I mean my lawyer I mean I don't know I'm
not an immigration expert not yet but
it's pretty unprecedented I mean my what
I believe is that they were trying to
um give me as many opportunities to fail
so they could like rearrest me and say
like I can't afford all the rules so
just kind of like a bit of a setup you
know so did you remove the apps entirely
from your phone from your devices so
you're not tempted yeah I don't even
have the passwords to my social media
accounts probably the smartest thing
there
um walk us through a typical day what
time do you get up what do you like to
order for breakfast walk us through from
start to finish uh well actually I wake
up pretty early
um I don't know why just like I don't
know
um like today I woke up like at five in
the morning
um and I just usually like catch up with
people in Europe
I have like lots of friends and like
um London especially how was this
experience changed you or has it you've
been to an ice Detention Center you have
served time at Rikers you are now 31
years old and living under house arrest
has this experience changed you
absolutely yes
um but I just learned so much and I met
so many people that wouldn't be exposed
to normally and
um yeah it's been like a huge learning
experience like all over I learned so
much about the system I got kind of like
The Human Experience and um a lot about
myself and I was a huge exercise like a
perseverance too so
are you in touch with your family yes
you are are they a big support system to
you right now um they are supportive I
wouldn't say that my primary support
system but they are I mean just because
they are not in the country so they
don't really know much about the system
so uh
like yeah
but they help as much as they can and
have been a touch for me throughout the
whole time I've been in jail and in
prison so do you have celebrity friends
uh Sam yes like who who do you turn to
um I don't want to put anybody on blast
so fair enough what about uh dating are
you dating these days no I was too busy
too busy for dating yes is that some
would you like to find love would you
like to start dating so I think it
pitched a lot of dating shows so oh
really yes
um but I'm trying to like just figure
out my own life so what's next for you
I'm hearing that there's also the
possibility of a reality television show
how much truth is there to that and if
there is truth what's the status of it
no there's no truth to that you would
not do a reality show absolutely not no
you bet you would do a dating show no
so this is where you come for some fresh
air all right yeah it's pretty I mean
it's better than jail so Anna what are
bringing you little sources of Joy these
days you say you're happy but what is
bringing you that happiness and joy I
just having
um I guess having my phone being able to
communicate with people not for like GTL
pay phone
um being able to like order fresh food
and salads
um having access to like internet
and I haven't been able to see my
friends not for like the plexiglass in
jail so yeah it's like little stuff like
this yeah so close definitely
[Music]